[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ela wird morgen
– wie alt wirst du noch mal? –
>> ELA: Fünf!
>> SALLY: fünf Jahre alt.
Und sie hat sich eine Peppa-Wutz-Torte gewünscht.
Eine Motivtorte haben wir schon gemacht
und jetzt gibt es eine Schlammtorte,
Schokoladen-Schlamm-Torte, oder?
Weil Peppa Wutz
>> ELA: liebt Schlamm.
>> SALLY: Ja, und Ela auch.
Aber jetzt zeigen wir erst mal, welche Zutaten wir brauchen.
Wir machen jetzt einen ganz einfachen Becherkuchen.
Also zum einen brauchen wir eine Prise Salz
und Vanilleextrakt.
Dann brauchen wir
>> ELA: Eier,
Zucker,
>> SALLY: Sauerrahm,
Öl,
– da nehmen wir ein Sonnenblumenöl,
ein neutrales.
Da haben wir hier
Mehl,
>> ELA: Mehl.
>> SALLY: Was ist das?
>> ELA: Kakao.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Nüsse
>> ELA: Nuss.
>> SALLY: und
>> SALLY & ELA: Backpulver.
>> SALLY: Yeah!
Jetzt tun wir mal zuerst die Eier nehmen.
Und auch bei den Eiern nehmen wir einen Becher voll Eier.
Ja. Und unsere Becher, die sind so drei viertel gefüllt.
Guck mal. Jetzt machst du das Ei hier rein.
Guck. Ich mache mal
– soll ich mal eins machen und du machst das nächste?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Schau mal. Ich mache das so.
Und wie mache ich es bei dir?
Okay, komm, bei dir machen wir es so.
Festhalten den Becher.
Und dann
mit beiden Händen
so.
>> ELA: Hm.
Aber nicht so fest, stimmt's?
>> SALLY: Genau, nicht zu fest.
Und guck mal. Hier immer an der Kante.
Hier.
Genau.
Noch mal.
Komm. Wir klopfen mal zusammen.
Und jetzt.
Guck mal, hier rein.
Da, wo es aufgebrochen ist.
>> ELA: Upsi!
>> SALLY: Upsi!
>> ELA: Es hat zum ersten Mal ein bisschen geklappt.
Ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen hat es nicht geklappt.
Ojemine!
Warte mal. Ich mache das mal kurz sauber.
>> ELA: Hm.
Ein Miniproblem.
Stimmt's?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> ELA: Ein Miniproblem.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist schon so ein kleines Miniproblem.
>> ELA: Warum hast du mir nicht als Baby Eierschälen
beigebracht?
>> SALLY: Du, die...
Ich nehme das jetzt einfach.
Es war ja alles sauber.
Die Samira war da ein bisschen
– wie sage ich da? –
geduldiger.
Aber wir probieren es gleich noch mal, okay?
>> ELA: Na gut.
>> SALLY: Soll ich die Eier machen?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Dann kannst du schon mal Hände waschen.
Nach den Eiern immer Hände waschen, ja?
>> ELA: Hm.
Warum?
>> SALLY: Damit unsere Hände sauber sind.
Okay, Ela.
Dann darfst du jetzt einen Becher Ei da reingeben.
>> ELA: Die ganzen?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Uh!
Das sieht aus, als würden wir jetzt Eier braten.
>> SALLY: Dann einen Becher Zucker hinterher.
Etwas Salz.
>> ELA: So was?
>> SALLY: Nimm ein bisschen weniger.
Mach mal ein bisschen noch mal zurück.
Ja, so ist es gut.
Und Vanilleextrakt,
deine Meisterdisziplin.
>> ELA: Ich kann es halt nicht anders.
>> SALLY: Stopp.
Ela?!
>> ELA: Was ist?
Wir Kinder...
Kinder mögen halt viel Zucker.
Tonka Wonka fehlt.
>> SALLY: Ach, willst du auch noch Tonka Wonka?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay, läuft bei dir.
>> ELA: Super!
>> SALLY: So?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gut. Und warte.
Bevor wir jetzt die Maschine anmachen,
müssen die Haare zurück.
Ich mache einfach so einen Knoten.
Und sehr vorsichtig, ja?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Schön schaumig rühren.
Ich habe da jetzt so eine Rutschmatte drunter,
damit die Schüssel nicht wegrutscht.
So, Turbo!
>> ELA: Machst du das dann da rein?
>> SALLY: Warte. Da muss man noch warten.
Das muss jetzt erst mal schaumig gerührt werden.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Vor der fünf kommt doch die vier.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Und nicht die drei.
>> SALLY: Stimmt!
Da steht 1, 3, 5.
Kannst du denen mal sagen, wie die Zahlen gehen?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Warte. Jetzt zuerst den Joghurt rein
>> ELA: Wenn jemand...
>> SALLY: – also den Schmand. Nicht das hier.
Okay.
Also wir haben jetzt hier Schmand, glaube ich, genommen
oder Sauerrahm, irgendwas, was wir im Kühlschrank hatten.
>> ELA: Sauerrahm.
>> SALLY: Sauerrahm?
Gut.
>> ELA: Auf geht's mit der Vanillecreme.
Das sieht aus wie eine Vanillecreme!
>> SALLY: So. Reinschütten.
Öl mit rein.
>> ELA: Achtung! Hier kommt eine Öldusche!
>> SALLY: Gut.
Und am Anfang darf man viel rühren,
aber, sobald jetzt die trockenen Zutaten dazu kommen,
nicht mehr viel rühren, ja?
Okay. Jetzt die Nüsse rein.
Ein Becher Mehl.
Ein Päckchen Backpulver.
Oh, warte. Da brauchen wir einen Löffel.
Jetzt kannst du mal ein bisschen Kakao hier reinmachen
in den Becher.
>> ELA: Aber nicht zu viel.
Kakao schmeckt ja eklig.
>> SALLY: Aber das wird doch zu Schokolade
mit Zucker zusammen.
Sollen wir mal einen halben Becher machen?
Komm. Mach noch ein bisschen,
damit es schön schokoladig wird.
So. Ja.
>> ELA: Und noch ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Für den David.
>> SALLY: Für den David, okay.
>> ELA: Yay!
>> SALLY: Wer ist denn der David?
>> ELA: Mein Freund.
>> SALLY: Vom Kindergarten?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ELA: Cool, dass er in meiner Gruppe ist.
>> SALLY: Ja, voll cool.
Und jetzt nur noch kurz rühren.
Nicht bei höchster Stufe.
Sonst
spritzt alles raus.
>> ELA: Mama, lass mich.
>> SALLY: Ja,
ich lasse dich.
>> ELA: Mama, aber vergiss nicht den Fondant.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber, Mama, diesmal brauchen wir Gras.
>> SALLY: Schatz...
Was?
>> ELA: So Grün.
>> SALLY: Was für Gras?
>> ELA: Mama, weißt du, was ich mit Gras meinte?
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: Fondant.
>> SALLY: Ah, okay.
>> ELA: Grünen!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Gut.
>> ELA: Mama, weißt du,
als wir noch das Lebkuchenhaus gemacht haben?
>> SALLY: So. Guck mal. Das reicht,
sobald sich alles verbunden hat.
Probieren?
Vorsicht.
>> ELA: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Ja? Ist es gut?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Gut.
Also dann fülle ich jetzt den Kuchen hier ein.
Wir haben die...
Ich habe die Backform bereits mit Backpapier eingeschlagen,
weil der Teig eben sehr flüssig ist.
[Musik]
Ich hatte vorhin Elas Schürze
– das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich hatte ihr die Schürze falschrum angezogen.
>> JOSH: Ja, ich habe es mir noch gedacht.
>> ELA: Und ich habe jetzt einfach weggezaubert.
>> SALLY: Egal.
>> ELA: So andersrum.
>> SALLY: Hast du es einfach andersrum gezaubert?
Okay.
Gut. Der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt.
Jetzt geht es direkt an die Schokoladencreme.
Matschkuchen!
Guck mal. Ich habe jetzt hier an Zutaten
– da habe ich jeweils 100 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade
und Vollmilchschokolade auch fein gehackt,
dann jeweils 250 Gramm Quark und Mascarpone,
ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt,
400 Gramm Sahne
und San-apart.
>> ELA: Quak, quak.
>> SALLY: Quak quak.
Jetzt müssen wir leider noch mal ein bisschen Geduld haben.
Denn die Schokolade muss geschmolzen werden.
Weißt du das?
>> ELA: Aber dafür können wir schon
mit den anderen Zutaten anfangen.
>> SALLY: Aber dafür können wir schon mal
Quark und Mascarpone verrühren. Das stimmt.
>> ELA: Ich will das Quark reinmachen.
>> SALLY: Den, den Quark, gell?
Warte, ich halte ihn.
Warte, ich kratze es dir kurz noch aus.
Du kannst du schon mal Vanilleextrakt dazu machen.
Das ist dein Spezialgebiet.
>> ELA: Ich kann es mir so süß machen,
wie ich will, stimmt's?
>> SALLY: Mach nicht so viel Vanille bitte.
Nicht so viel.
Ruhig noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, das muss reichen.
>> ELA: Schön, dass ich noch was am Rand habe.
Noch dran.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Ach, Ela!
Sollen wir
"Drei Chinesen mit dem Kontrabass" tanzen?
Hm?
Drei Chinesen mit dem Kontrabass...
Was tanzen wir?
Sag mir, dann tanzen wir es.
>> ELA: Das da.
>> SALLY: So?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay, wir machen jetzt so,
"Head, Shoulders, Knees and Toes", okay?
Guck zu mir.
Head,
shoulders,
knees
and toes.
Okay?
Head...
[Musik]
Und? Ist die Schokolade geschmolzen?
Noch nicht ganz.
>> ELA: Dann machen wir jetzt mal einen anderen Tanz.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Welchen?
Welchen machen wir solange, he?
>> ELA: So.
[Musik]
Kann ich bitte verrühren?
>> SALLY: Okay. Die Schokolade ist jetzt geschmolzen
und kann jetzt auch eingerührt werden.
Warte, ein bisschen höher.
Hier, rühr, rühr, rühr!
Rühr, Baby, rühr!
Nee, nee, nee! Nicht hoch!
>> ELA: Das ist aber so schwer.
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich mache es kurz.
Okay. Warte kurz. Ich schütte kurz die Schokolade rein.
Warte kurz. Ups!
>> ELA: Ich will die machen.
>> SALLY: Soll ich sie dir mal – warte.
Jetzt kannst du.
Ich habe halt nur das Gefühl, du siehst sie dann nicht, weißt.
Wir müssen nur schnell arbeiten,
weil, wenn du die Schokolade da jetzt reinfließen lässt
und die fest wird,
haben wir lauter Schokobrocken in der Creme.
Deswegen muss man die eigentlich rühren
und direkt noch reinschütten.
Aber du kannst mir gleich,
wenn ich so weit bin, die Sahne dazu gießen.
Gleich, ja?
Guck mal. Magst du die Sahne gießen
und ich soll es halten?
Ich halte das.
>> ELA: Ja. Jetzt?
>> SALLY: Also hier erst mal alle Zutaten verrühren
und jetzt die Sahne langsam dazu.
>> ELA: Oh! Das ist aber schon viel.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und es war auch nicht so langsam.
Dann spritzt es nämlich.
Haben wir schon Vanille rein?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Gut.
Super aufgepasst.
Und jetzt mit San-apart steif schlagen.
Komm. Mach du die rein.
>> ELA: Einen nur?
>> SALLY: Aber zähl mal mit.
Okay. Aber guck mal, immer so flach machen.
So.
Zwei.
Ja.
Ja, so ist gut.
>> ELA & SALLY: Drei.
>> ELA: Und?
>> SALLY: Noch mal.
>> ELA: Das Letzte?
>> SALLY: Nee, noch ein bisschen mehr.
Sechs Stück brauche ich.
Nee, noch bisschen mehr sogar, zehn Stück.
>> ELA: Vier.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und noch einen Löffel.
>> ELA: Acht.
>> SALLY: Super!
So.
>> ELA: Ah, kann ich den abschlecken?
Die zwei?
>> SALLY: Probier mal.
Sag mal, wie es schmeckt.
Wie ist die Schokocreme geworden?
Nicht gut?
>> ELA: Doch.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also komm. Dann holen wir jetzt den Kuchen und füllen ihn.
>> ELA: Kann ich noch einmal?
>> SALLY: Warte. Dann gebe ich dir einen frischen Löffel.
>> ELA: Warum?
>> SALLY: Weil man nicht mit dem benutzten Löffel rein darf.
Man muss immer einen frischen nehmen
oder so einen Probierlöffel machen, weißt du.
Sonst geht ja deine Spucke da mit rein.
Das ist doch nicht so gut, gell?
Aber ich habe hier noch was zum Abschlecken.
>> ELA: Soll ich?
>> SALLY: Warte, warte, warte!
Wir müssen doch den Kuchen erst mal rauslösen.
>> ELA: Ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe mich doch nur bereit gemacht.
>> SALLY: Warte. Und durchschneiden.
Warte, warte, warte!
>> ELA: Durchschneiden?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Warum?
>> SALLY: Dass du innen drin auch Schokolade hast.
So.
>> ELA: Wieso denn?
>> SALLY: Jetzt kannst du ihn füllen.
Der Kuchen wird übrigens ein bisschen höher,
wenn man die Eier-Zucker-Masse länger verrührt,
wie man hier sieht.
Ich habe den jetzt noch mal gebacken,
damit wir später auch eine Torte zum Anschneiden haben.
Denn die ist ja für morgen.
Gell?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Guck mal.
Soll ich dir mal was zeigen?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, so.
>> ELA: Mama, ich habe eine bessere Idee,
wie ich es machen würde.
>> SALLY: Ich habe Angst.
Ich habe Angst,
wenn du sagst: "Ich habe eine bessere Idee."
>> ELA: Oh!
>> SALLY: O Gott im Himmel!
>> ELA: Alter, Jesses!
>> SALLY: Jesses!
"Alter, Jesses", habe ich gesagt.
Das war Alter, Jesses.
Jesses!
>> SALLY: Ojemine!
Oh, dieses Kind!
>> ELA: Alter, Jesses!
So. Ela, hier.
Verteil die schon mal schön, ja?
>> ELA: Guck mal, ob ich das gut mache.
>> SALLY: Ja, mega!
Ich habe nur Angst, das Versteck zu zeigen hier,
das hier.
>> ELA: Mama, ich werde aber an meinem Geburtstag vier.
>> SALLY: Nee, du wirst ja fünf.
Magst du Schokolade mit
Erdbeeren,
Yogurette an den Rand?
>> SALLY: Guck mal.
>> ELA: Was ist Yogurette?
>> SALLY: Das hier.
Und...
Wow, das sieht super aus!
Richtig professionell, Schatz.
Sieht echt gut aus.
Sieht aus wie so eine Matsche-
– wie so eine Matschparty.
Jetzt hole ich kurz eine Tortenplatte.
>> ELA: Kann ich eins naschen?
>> SALLY: Nein, wir naschen es doch gleich mit der Torte.
Okay.
>> ELA: Bitte! Nur eins ohne Torte.
>> SALLY: Aber dann darfst du heute
keine Torte mehr naschen, ja?
Morgen dann erst.
Aber jetzt warte mal, weil ich glaube
– warte, warte, warte, warte!
Wir haben gleich was übrig.
Dann kannst du die nehmen.
Aber lass uns erst mal den Rand der Torte fertig machen.
Guck mal. Jetzt streichen wir nämlich hier noch
ein bisschen Creme an den Rand.
Und gleich gibt es noch eine Überraschung für dich.
>> ELA: Und was für eine?
Ah, du darfst es ja nicht verraten.
>> SALLY: Ganz genau.
>> ELA: Aber morgen kommt
>> SALLY: Und jetzt...
>> ELA: eine Annabell dran.
>> SALLY: Jetzt nimmst du die und tust die an den Rand.
Aber ich glaube, wir halbieren die.
Also alle mal auspacken und dann
halbieren, ja?
Aber das machen wir mit dem Messer.
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Ich mache das kurz so.
Ich halbiere es und du legst es dann an den Rand.
>> ELA: Mama, wie wäre es, ich...
Ich nehme mir ein kleineres Messer.
>> SALLY: Oh, halbiert ist zu klein.
Ela, halbieren ist zu klein.
Wir müssen sie doch ein bisschen größer lassen.
So.
Guck mal. Ich schneide sie
und du legst sie an den Rand, okay?
Wie so einen Zaun.
Kannst du mir beim Auspacken helfen?
Warte. Die Kleinen brauchen wir nicht.
Die können wir dann gleich noch...
>> ELA: Die da?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Das ist halt jetzt so eine richtige
Kindermatschetorte.
Halt, halt, halt! Nicht alle Reste essen.
Das geht nicht, das geht nicht.
Das reicht jetzt.
>> ELA: Ja, ich will doch nicht essen.
Ups!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Okay, Ela.
Jetzt darfst du deine Torte fertig dekorieren.
>> MURAT: Und du bist
ein ganz großer Künstler geworden, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ah, du sollst sie doch dekorieren, nicht essen.
>> MURAT: Ela!
>> SALLY: Zu früh gelobt.
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> MURAT: Das ist voll schön!
>> ELA: So. Nichts mehr.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Oh, wie schön!
>> MURAT: Ela?
>> ELA: Aber das ist doch der Zauberstab
von der anderen Peppa Wutz.
>> SALLY: Aber den kann man doch hier drauflegen.
>> ELA: Nein!
>> SALLY: Weil die andere Torte ist doch schon voll dekoriert.
>> SALLY: Nein? Okay. Die legen wir zu der anderen. Okay.
>> ELA: Ja, wir müssen die doch in die Hand machen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Darf ich dich mal was fragen, Ela?
Aber du musst die Wahrheit sagen, okay?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Wenn du groß bist – okay? –
>> SALLY: Hier.
>> MURAT: und – hörst du mir zu?
>> SALLY & ELA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wenn du groß bist,
möchtest du dann so werden wie die Mama
oder wie der Papa?
>> ELA: Wie Papa.
>> SALLY: Echt jetzt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> ELA: Echt jetzt.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und warum?
>> SALLY: Wo soll das hin, Schatz?
>> MURAT: Und warum möchtest du so werden wie der Papa?
>> ELA: Weil Papa so schlau ist.
>> SALLY: Und ist die Mama nicht schlau?
>> ELA: Doch.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und ist die Mama größer oder der Papa?
>> ELA: Papa
nicht.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Wo kommt das hin?
>> MURAT: Und wer bekommt jetzt Hausarrest?
>> SALLY: Der Papa,
weil er versucht, ein Kind zu manipulieren.
>> MURAT: Ela, habe ich dich manipuliert?
Gut.
>> SALLY: Weißt du überhaupt, was das bedeutet?
>> MURAT: Weißt du, was manipulieren bedeutet?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: Mh.
>> SALLY: Nicht mit der Schokolade.
>> ELA: Das mit den anderen...
>> SALLY: Wenn man die so beeinflusst, nicht?
>> MURAT: Man kann auch schon
– du musst die Kinder immer motivieren, Sally.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und immer...
Und ihre
– wie soll ich es sagen? –
positiven Fähigkeiten loben.
>> SALLY: Ja, mache ich doch.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ela, buchstabier mal Steueridentifikationsnummer.
>> ELA: Ups!
>> SALLY: Ups!
Sag Papa: "Ich kann voll toll schon kopfrechnen."
Gell,
>> ELA: Ich kann schon
>> SALLY: mein Schatz?
>> ELA: voll toll kopfrechnen.
>> SALLY: Du darfst immer sagen, was du selber möchtest.
Okay, Ela, deine Torte ist jetzt fertig.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber die können wir heute gar nicht probieren.
Denn die kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann warten wir drauf,
bis deine Freunde morgen da sind, okay?
>> ELA: Und dann schneiden wir sie an.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay, tschau.
>> MURAT: Cool. Eine coole Matschtorte.
>> SALLY: Ich zeige euch jetzt...
Ich zeige euch jetzt noch
>> ELA: Zeig mal meinem Papa die Torte.
>> SALLY: die kleine Überraschung,
>> SALLY: die Überraschung für Ela.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Da die Torte jetzt höher ist,
habe ich die auch ein bisschen besser füllen können.
Ich habe sie nämlich zweimal durchgeschnitten.
Jetzt hier den Rand der Torte schön bestreichen.
Aber das sind halt so Dinge, die lasse ich dann weg,
wenn Ela oder Samira mitbacken, weil ich mir so denke:
Hauptsache, die Kids haben Spaß dabei.
Das lernen sie alles irgendwann noch.
Und ich meinte, Ela ist es im Prinzip egal,
ob die Torte ein- oder zweimal gefüllt ist.
Das ist ja eher so mein erwachsener Anspruch.
Aber selbst hier, seht ihr,
muss man sich gar nicht verkünsteln.
Denn das wird sowieso eine Matschetorte.
So einfach den Rand aber noch schön bestreichen,
damit da gleich
die Süßigkeiten draufpassen.
Und dann mache ich noch ein bisschen Creme drauf
Und so geht es dann auch perfekt auf.
Weil ich habe hier noch Creme von Ela übrig gehabt,
aber jetzt noch mal Creme,
die gleiche Portion für die Torte gemacht
und dann geht es vom Rezept her auch ideal auf.
Guckt.
Das muss nicht perfekt sein.
Und hier obendrauf darf es und soll es auch wellig sein.
Denn das sind gleich Matschepfützen.
Jetzt muss ich tatsächlich nur kurz abmessen.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach Duplo.
Aber ich finde
– ah, ein bisschen würde ich sie schon kürzen.
Sonst wird es zu hoch.
Ja, so ist es gut.
Und gar nicht gleich hoch,
also wirklich mal tiefer, mal höher.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich noch ein bisschen Kakao für die Oberfläche.
Denn ich finde sogar, dass die Schokocreme
ein bisschen zu hell ist für Matsch.
Deswegen wird jetzt noch ein bisschen gematscht.
Noch ein paar Krümel.
Einfach die Restsüßigkeiten so ein bisschen.
Und dann gibt es Elas Überraschung.
Und zwar kriegt sie
noch ein paar Spielfiguren von mir.
Und deswegen habe ich sie jetzt auch weggeschickt,
dass sie das nicht sieht.
Denn hier habe ich noch die Peppa-Wutz-Spielfiguren.
Warte.
Ich bin Peppa Wutz.
Das ist mein kleiner Bruder Schorsch.
Das ist mir Mama Wutz.
Und das ist Papa Wutz.
[Grunzlaut]
Ich habe die vorher übrigens abgewaschen.
Und die, die tun doch alle immer so im Schlamm,
im Matsch, in Matschpfützen.
Ich liebe es immer, wenn Peppa Wutz endet mit:
"Peppa liebt Matschepfützen.
Schorsch liebt Matschepfützen."
Und dann kommen so alle.
"Alle lieben Matschepfützen!
Hahaha."
Und dann: Di-di-di-di-dit,
di-di-di-di-dit!
So. Und das ist die Peppa-Wutz-Matschtorte.
Die bekommt Ela morgen zum Geburtstag.
Und zum einen wird sie natürlich richtig gut schmecken
und zum anderen ist sie supereinfach nachzumachen,
auch für euch zu Hause.
Und ich finde, sie sieht echt cool aus,
trifft das Thema perfekt.
Eigentlich wollte ich die jetzt für euch anschneiden
und sagen: "Kommt. Wir probieren sie."
Aber ich bringe es echt nicht übers Herz.
Also
die Torte kann ich leider nicht anschneiden.
Die kriegt Ela auch morgen zum Geburtstag.
Dann hat sie jetzt ihre eigene Torte gebacken,
die Torte und dann haben wir noch die Motivtorte.
Und das passt dann auch.
Dann haben wir jetzt drei Kuchen.
Wir sind gar nicht so viele.
Wir machen es echt nur ganz, ganz klein.
Von daher,
dieses Rezept findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de
oder in meiner App.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüssi!
[Musik]